all right guys right now we're going to
give a call to my boy old chad over
there
and he was really close with billy
conforto and
you know i remember billy he really
billy was a beautiful fellow man one of
the only homosexual men that ever stood
up for me
praise god bro
we miss you man he's upstairs dog
hello
what's up big dog
all right hey what's up man
can you hear me better now
yeah it hit a lot better now hey man bro
dude so what's going on y'all where
y'all living at in the tent
we're staying right where we got flooded
at
oh really
yeah we
threw some furniture out and started
staying on some old
sofas and all that waiting for fema to
try to help out damn man y'all indoors
are outdoors
we're indoors and saying we just got
electricity yesterday
oh yeah what's the first thing y'all did
when you got it
sure we we've been going across the
street they got a church because our
water was off too so we had to go bathe
on the side where the water came out on
the church oh that's a baptism right
there that you do yes yeah that's what i
was saying i went over there and i was
like i said a little praying before you
[Laughter]
bro you trick me down you triple
baptized now man you certified you might
be a pastor bro one more bath you might
be a pastor yeah that's what i'm talking
about i think the holy ghost came in
oh man dude thank you so much for uh for
jumping on with me today man i just you
know everybody on the podcast man loves
billy man everybody loves billy comfort
and misses him and
and misses him being alive man i just
want you to
can you share with me just a good billy
story or something
yeah which is sure
i listened to the one when y'all was um
you were talking to billy's brother
chucky or whatever oh yeah no it's
yeah we all was talking about you and
billy used to go out and use my my name
my id oh yeah did we use your well
my idea i lost mine and billy was always
he used anybody's id
yeah he did anybody's name i think i got
a couple tickets stealing
dude we had fun man i remember
well the funny thing about billy bro was
he would like say if you were at
somebody's house bro you were at just
anybody's house you're at somebody's
house
when that when that other person went
out of the room he would always be like
bruh
i think [__] danny likes me bruh and
i'm like
i'm like dude danny's nine years old
like danny doesn't
yeah he used to do that to me
he loved doing that [__] he always he
loved people he always like trying to
create like a little mystery
would you walk out to go use the
bathroom if you were in there he's like
you seen the way he's looking at yeah
yeah
like really
yeah dude yeah just ridiculous man
billy was funny bro and he was tough too
dude tell me he he used to be able to
fight right
yeah you know him and all
the the dimensions they are boss no sure
i even did it for a little while but
they uh
they said you know they all passed away
huh
well yeah i know some of them did man
jimmy and ronnie that's what's his
cousins
the fighters
and how they
died
um i think it was into
drugs or whatever oh pills drugs huh
yeah
and billy hit an embankment huh
oh
yeah and then even deshawn you remember
sean was the one i was um oh yeah
deshawn was fine dawg
i was only friends with you because of
the sun
yeah she um she passed away too oh man
i'm sorry bro
damn yeah
i think you had answer to one of your
dances or whatever she was gonna go
instead of billy and her was gonna go
with you i'm sure i didn't
oh yeah oh billy tried to come to our
prom i remember that he'd be like
because billy loved dressing up and [__]
he's like bro
that might have been it bro he was going
he was gonna find him with somebody yeah
dude billy was the most fun man what's
something that you miss about him
she probably everything out probably
pretty much his compassion right he had
a heart for everybody in that race
yeah i don't know it's just it don't
matter who you was if you if you you
needed something he'll help you out
he'll give you his laugh
yeah he would man he would give you one
of his legs bro if he had a [__]
if he had a wooden leg he'd give you
that [__] so you could row a boat
yeah didn't chase you with the one leg
he got yeah whatever
trying to take the dog people out
walking on one leg
bro he was like bro he would take a
wooden arm off and train a [__] pit
bull to bite on that [__] man
remember when he would get the dogs to
jump up onto the roof
yeah but like sometimes he's um
hanging on like a rope from a limb and
he had a dog jump up there and grab it
and it won't come down to it jump that
rim off the humming um
branch off that tree
oh dude he took a [__] rain gutter
off a whole [__] uh off a ranch style
home one time with those dogs i saw him
do it man
bro he was like the [__] gay he was
kind of like the gay michael vick i
think
he was special bro how did you meet him
man so were you guys cousins or what was
that because i don't remember exactly
how you guys uh met each other
it was it was a
strange i was with um deshaun was their
cousin and uh
me and design started dating in like
fourth grade
dang him bro
and she uh
she i guess was together about
eight years as um so we all we
you know during through high school and
stuff we went together but we
got back together when i was like 19 and
stayed together until she passed
damn man i didn't know you guys were
together when she passed man i'm sorry
bro
was it kind of hard at the end where a
lot of people were dealing with
addiction over there
yeah i guess that's what um
everybody was addicted to like pain
medicine i don't know when all them
people were going to doctors out here
and all that
oh yeah man well dude i remember billy
so billy set me up with this girl one
time did you work over there with us by
the our restaurant
which one y'all was that the broken egg
or something no we work at this place
called chefs bro i don't even think they
had a kitchen in that [__] dude
i don't know what we were selling bro
damn y'all serving tv dinners oh i think
we just
broke people
dinner
i think
i don't know what we would
the more i think about i think we had a
freezer and a bunch of bus boys i don't
think anybody in that [__] had a food
he was in the freezer you know dessert
like hold on
billy bring this team dinner outside
billy was so professional too bro billy
loved dressing up for work he was he'd
be like oh your order will be right out
sir he was always so professional
i was so i was too like i tried to do it
but i was so embarrassed like i was shy
like embarrassed to talk to people and
stuff start stuttering
like god damn
billy's like yeah
yeah billy was a g at it man yeah
yeah i miss him man he loved those dogs
too bro and dude here's what i didn't
like though
he had some crazy weed
so we get all gassed up dude we [__]
high as [__] and then those dogs would
start looking at me and i would say he
knew i was scared of dogs
and he would be like he'd always say
[__] like don't worry i'll protect you
and i'm like [__] that's your dog and
your weed this whole thing is a set up
dog
[__]
man they were staring at you oh them
dogs are everybody dude it was funny man
and dog
he has some beautiful dogs though man um
so where you at now you living by the
church what you gonna do man y'all still
y'all still struggling down there huh
a lot of people just starting to get
their electricity but
i'm just waiting on
i guess fema or something to
do something i can't really do nothing
dang man
well look man i just want to say man out
of my heart you know billy did so many
nice things for me man uh
you know he just he stood up for me you
know there was times he was like a
little bit of an older brother
he gave me steroids bro that i don't
even think we're any good but i [__]
still lifted [__] dude right
yep your phone's real choppy what is it
i don't know is it still choppy now no
no it's not
all right see i remember when he was
y'all was doing on steroids and stuff oh
yeah boy we was downstairs we was
[__] checked
and billy would always wear these blue
shorts he'd be like bro i can't go to
the gym man i can't find my blue shorts
dog get some other shores man
some short shorts for the guys to look
at
i think it was like some board shorts i
don't know what it was dude but he'd
always be like bro i think that guy over
there is looking at me
and it would be like a blind dude some
blind dude in a [__] standing there
with a walking stick i'm like that
dude's [__] blind bro
no he's not he's not yeah
oh dude so billy one time set me up with
a girl
so he gave me a soma pill he's like this
will help you relax right
dude i've never taken a [__] soma
phil in my life right
so first off about nine minutes after he
gives it to me i take a right turn
and i took it about 30 yards after the
turn right
so i drove right into a [__] ditch
right
yeah i know this the song was like what
muscle relaxed i think cause he i was
with billy one time and he gave me like
he told me to take like two of them
whatever he's like here take this i was
riding with him back from the doctor she
was going to the doctor and we i said
well i'm hungry bro so we stopped at a
taco bell and i guess the soul must make
you like shake or whatever
i got a taco supreme i went sit down i
guess when they kicked in i shook all
the supreme over they had nothing but
meatloaf
yeah
yeah you ever been so filled up you
shook the supreme off a taco bro
i'm like what's wrong
why am i shaking
come on they're looking at you it's time
to go i'm like what did you give me
damn dude you leave out of there with
you it looks like a dog that just got a
haircut on the table it's just toppings
look at cheese lettuce
i got a shell and the meat left
shook my whole supreme off
damn avoid them so
dude the psalmist will take your supreme
baby
them [__] make your [__] lips wet
and they'll take you supreme so then
look what happened was bro so we he
still said bro you can't stand this girl
up dude you can't be you got to be a
gentleman bro i'm like stand this girl
up i said i can't stand up
he's like [__] it bra i got you dawg so
we go do we go to this nightclub over
there in fat city right
right over there in metairie when you
get off the causeway we go over there
dude
escapes or kenny's key west huh some
[__] hole dude it was dicey bro there
was a lot of people in there some dude
drinking cologne in the corner
nice
it had a boxing ring in the middle of
the club like dicey okay
but uh
so anyway billy walks i can't even stand
up dude i can't even stand up it's like
weekend at [__] bernie dude he walks
me in there
he's like bro nobody will notice if we
play that song electric slide right he
puts that [__] on the jukebox i'm like
what the [__] dude
so fast forward anyway he's like dude
the girl shows up i can't even see her
that's how [__] high i can't even see
her
she ends up being nice she gives me a
ride home across the calls way back to
uh
mandeville
bro
at some point i was so sick it's just me
and her she's driving my car back i
puked all over her
so
i get home in the morning
i come out to my car the whole inside is
filled with puke except for the space
where she had been sitting driving
and i don't know where she is bro
you've never seen a since i've never
seen her since dude
but damn billy always had an adventure
man
well she's crazy
that's a lot man well look man on behalf
of the podcast man we're gonna send you
500 bucks just to [__] do put a
little jingle in the pocket over there
buy some [__] dinner for your boy buy
some popeyes for your neighbor or
whatever um
and i just want to say man i love you
bro and i love billy man and and thanks
for jumping on a call today with me
yeah all right i love you too well
i'll still keep in touch with you man
yeah 100 man i'll hit you up this week
or something if you need something hit
me up man uh
and then whenever i come home dude we
got to go catch up we raised some money
for billy i was telling we sold a bunch
of t-shirts we want to put a like a
bench at like a dog park or something
all right yeah when you come in town or
whatever just um
hit me up and i'll call me and you're
gonna take a ride or do whatever you
want to do gang bro
all right chad be good dude we'll hit
you with uh we'll hit you guys up on uh
i'll have the producer hit you guys up
man and um and we'll talk to you later
on dude thanks again all right thank you
all
right man
we gotta find some pictures of belly man
that's what we gotta find
we gotta find some pictures we're gonna
get the dog bench built
got to do a little bit of work left
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one